okay let's do it and we back at it not a
long intro today guys cuz a little kind
of a long intro that I'm gonna be
yapping with you guys about but you know
once again I welcome back to riff room
with Griffin I want to thank everybody
for watching subscribing sharing
listening you know listening on on all
the audio places watching on YouTube
clips on Instagram and all that I really
appreciate you guys listening to the
podcast it's been difficult during this
quarantine to try to like put out
episodes and try to collect guests so
like for instance this particular
episode I filmed long you know not a
long time ago but it seems like a long
time ago because of how fast the news
cycle goes so I mean just always some
new interesting or crazy thing to talk
about and then it's like you have
somebody on the podcast then you wish
man I wish they were on you know now as
opposed to three weeks ago or four weeks
ago so this particular episode is like
all just talking about quarantine and
comedy and with the great Godfrey the
comedian Godfrey is great I actually
also did another episode with him but
the audio got messed up where we talk
about the George Floyd and all that kind
of stuff but this episode is still
really good the kind of the discussion
we get into is really bright dude and
and I wanted to still release that
episode because I put out content every
single week but that being said let me
take some time in my intro to this
episode to address some things that have
been going on recently in the news um so
I mean as you know the the whole big
thing the news cycle came out and
and the big story came out about my
friend chris d'elia let me just say this
Christie Lee is my friend I've known him
for many years um you know we're work
colleagues we see each other at the
store you know but we're friends you
know it's like if he some life event
happened I would think that he would hit
me up and be like hey Eric boom boom so
he's my friend he's he got into some
trouble he's having some trouble times
is it okay that I take some time to
disseminate the information is it okay
that I did I take some time to have some
compassion from my friend that you know
what he's going through and and really
taking a beat before I just go on my
podcast and just talk about whatever I
want to talk about I don't appreciate
this attitude that people have had that
like you know if you don't talk about it
here somehow condoning bad behavior no
that's not what it is at all
can we I don't let the social media
universe dictate what I should talk
about or when I should talk about it you
know it's like I don't need some sort of
virtue signaling for me to be like oh
that is an important thing I mean I felt
this way when the George Floyd stuff
happened and then we started with the
protests and the riots and then black
lives matter and so then you feel the
pressure of like man I got to put
something out because it's like if you
don't put anything out you're a racist
that's what people would say to it like
if you're white I'm saying you know like
if you're a white person or white
celebrity you're like hey if you're not
using your platform to talk about you
know black lives matter that it means
you're you you're the other side in the
same way I feel about this situation
that happened with my friend Chris just
because I didn't talk about it right
away just because I didn't publicly bash
the dude or whatever some people have
done it doesn't mean I condone bad
behavior
it's just that hey can I take a beat and
like think about everything and see all
the information that's coming out before
I just go boom so that's what I did and
that's why I'm here now
but the real discussion I have about it
because I didn't want
necessarily talked about that
specifically by myself I'm a solo
podcast host um some people do it and
that's fine that's good for them but not
for me because I felt like it was an
important subject so I actually went on
Ric Glassman's podcast speak for say
speak for yourself that's a whole other
show take your shoes off I went to
Rick's place and it's a whole big thing
because of his OCD but it was great we
had I think we had a very interesting
thoughtful nuanced discussion so and
here's a little clip here's a little
clip from that right now I'm not scared
to talk about it I'm annoyed that people
I'm annoyed that my parents for right or
wrong are telling me what to tweet boom
ID okay
we're on the same page with that I don't
mind talking about this subject I know
it's hot button I know it's nuanced I
know it's it's a hard discussion it's
layered I don't have a problem talking
about it
but I do have a problem you telling me
when where and how I should talk about
it which I do think speaking for myself
there is something to look into why am I
so triggered when people tell me what to
do so there you have it so if you really
want to hear us go into depth about that
go there but what I want to talk about
here is that listen I don't condone any
bad behavior curses own statement that
he put out you know I wish it was a more
in I wish the statement was more but I
also I understand why it wasn't you know
when you're accused of a criminal
criminal act if you're accused of a
crime you have to be careful about what
you say I mean it you know lawyers get
involved it becomes a legal matter or
people think it would become a legal
matter so you really have to like be
careful and it's unfortunate that it's
like that but hey that's the world we
live in so he put out a statement you
know what he said in his statement was
he let the livestock get out of hand
listen like people act like if you're
friends with him that we somehow know
everything about the guy and no I don't
know everything about him but what I do
know of him is that he's a a type
personality male that got what a lot of
women you know in in his in times that
I've known him for over 10 years you
know I don't know I haven't been to one
city doing comedy that a girl hasn't
asked me hey do you know Chris D'Elia
um I go to this health place and the
girls there asked me like hey you're a
comic do you know Chris D'Elia so I know
there are a lot of people that were very
happy to know him be a fan of his and
try to actually have relationships with
him so now did he handle those
relationships in the best possible way
obviously not being a nice person is
what the this is all about I don't think
Chris was the nicest guy to women his
fur though passed however long it was
you know I think that he's older now I
think um you know I think he's gonna
learn from this but hey you know that's
all I'm gonna speak on about about that
I'm not gonna speak for him but this
basically boils down to just being nice
to people I have a great discussion like
I said with Rick Glassman about I would
say about my own behavior I want to put
it on me and the thing that I want to
talk about now and my little intro right
now is just to say that you know we're
talking a lot about systemic racism but
I think we need to start talking about
systemic systemic misogyny because I
think it goes hand-in-hand big news that
came out and I'm a gamer now I stream a
lot on Twitch which is aircraft and
gaming I play video games and now I'm
hearing that you know some women that
work for a certain game companies they
putting out information that in the
streaming world is there's more of that
sort of like inappropriate behavior
going on and I go damn so it's not just
in comedy it's not just la comedians
it's not just New York comedians or
wherever it's not you know apparently
it's men everywhere you know in politics
and entertainment and in gaming and just
regular everyday life so we obviously
have some sort of problem that that we
should address it like that it's
systemic misogyny you know and I can
only speak for myself I have not always
acted in the best behavior but I think
that it's case-by-case you know what I
think is flirting somebody else might
think is hey that's inappropriate
I might flirt the same way with ten
different people and like three times it
works great but it still could be
inappropriate so you know I'm taking
some account for myself some
accountability and going damn you know
you got a you got a look at this and go
assess your own behavior you know and so
I can look at now myself and be like
have
I treated every female that I've come
across respectfully and nice probably
not have I been inappropriate have I you
know made it sexual when I just and then
use the excuse of like well I was just
flirting or you know it's just guys
being guys now I'm starting to look at
it and being like oh no that's actually
that's not a good excuse it's actually
like depending on the circumstance you
should know as the person to be like oh
I probably shouldn't have approached it
that way I mean for instance like I so
now I think about like all the young you
know up-and-coming female comics you
know if you're a young female comic
you're attractive and you're coming
around a comment that you say you might
admire or you might be like hey I like
what you do and I want to do what you do
and then that person me I'm just gonna
speak for me if I turn that into
something like oh hey any flirty that
might be inappropriate hey it might work
one or two times it might be like that
person might also be interested but I
guess as a man now you know you got to
start to look and be like hey there's a
time and place for everything and the
real question I think the real thing to
say for me and even when I look back at
the Kris situation is just because you
can doesn't mean you should so that
being said you know I have to look back
and be like I wish I could I wish I can
go back and say to every single female
that I've ever made uncomfortable I you
know I'm sorry you know I wish I could
and I don't want to say it like that on
here even though I sort of just said
that but I don't because I'm not gonna I
don't want to sit here and act like
every time you flirt with somebody it's
wrong I think it's Kate's case-by-case
I think it's nuanced I think it's a
larger discussion and I think the larger
discussion is what I'm talking about is
we should be nicer to each other it's
the same thing with race with the race
issue you should be we should just be
nicer to each other we should be
respectful and I think as men with this
systemic misogyny I'm gonna call it is
that we it's not we're not we're not
nice enough we're not respectful enough
we're not appreciative enough of our
females and
I think we just have to do better I mean
I'm uncomfortable even talking about
this right now like this but this is
just the only way I could do it it's
just for me to just be as vulnerable as
possible just to be like what damn I'm
sorry you know like I did you know
because it's like we as a man I don't
understand how it is so I have to like
figure out some analogies I have to
figure out like how would it be for me
in this situation especially for like
colleagues like work people you know
that's the thing you have to really
think about too like you don't like if
you if you as a man or always are always
turning it into something you know
sexual or then it's like Dan that that
makes the other person uncomfortable and
you know you don't even realize that
you're you're doing that until you find
out later and they're like well yeah it
wasn't comfortable so uh you know it is
like I say a larger discussion about
like teaching young men the importance
of respecting females and and rotten you
know raising them up and understanding
that it's not easy for them to be in a
situation where they feel threatened or
they feel uncomfortable or there's some
weird power dynamic that they feel like
well if I don't you know respond this
way this person is going to maybe get
mad at me or they are or they're gonna
lose something from this situation and
so you know I'm starting to flip my
brain and starting to really think about
it I'm hearing a lot of stories from you
know females on on Instagram you're
looking at all these stories and you're
seeing that you know their experiences
and you're just going damn you know [ __ ]
we got to do better guys so we just we
really have to do better we have to like
I said treat people nice respectful and
so you know that being said again I have
a great discussion with Rick Glassman on
the take your shoes off podcaster that
that's coming out probably I think it
came out today the same day that this is
coming out so make sure you check that
out
listen I don't know if I'm doing this
subject justice and I really didn't want
to sit here and talk about you know it's
like I don't want to be clickbait like
you know Eric riff it talks about Chris
D'Elia cuz that's not what this
about I think the situation with Chris
he's now a lightning rod for a larger
discussion and those and that larger
discussion is misogyny and and how we're
treating women and we just all have to
do better I can look at myself and be
like damn I should do better even when
it works out good for instance I the way
I flirted with my current girlfriend you
know we've been together four years now
and you know we had like a breakup in
the middle and but anyway the point is
if I look back at how that interaction
went it just happened to work you know
because just the way the way that back
and forth you know the way the back and
forth went you know but I could if she
wasn't interested she could easily be
like oh man he made me so uncomfortable
or look what he said to me and now I'm
sitting I'm look looking back on it
being like I can't look back on her to
be like well I was just flirting I just
you know I thought you know like you
know when you're doing something you you
know you can even if you don't know in
the moment you should be able to look
back and be like [ __ ] that was creepy or
damn that was inappropriate and so you
know I don't know not everybody talks
like this I'm just looking back and say
I'm not speaking for anyone else I'm not
speaking for Chris and I'm speaking for
anyone just for me I can look back on my
own behavior and be like ah I probably
shouldn't have said that
just a little you know look at me guys
I'm not I ain't the most attractive
[ __ ] in the world so when I got
on TV and started to things started to
happen and people started where it
started to be interested in me in a way
that they never have my whole life I
probably let it go to my head too but
imagine being a a-type personality
attractive you know it's not an excuse
by any means believe me it's not an
excuse I'm just saying I understand and
you should be able to look back on and
be like whoa let's take a beat and
really check our behavior and start you
know start doing better I mean a lot of
those stories that I looked at about
Chris a lot of it is just not nice you
know what I mean like you know I think
he could have treated some of these
women nicer um that's just me being
honest you know I love the guy I do
and you know you know that's really all
I want to say about that and I just
think there's a lot of hurt feelings and
if you have countless people who are
like well I didn't like how you treated
me I think you got a look at yourself
and be like okay I could do better you
know and I think that he will I hope
that he will you know I have faith that
he will I think that he's gonna learn
from this experience and be like alright
you know and he's got a whole new life
now so that's all I'm gonna say about
that but to get back to it I just think
that we can't just talk about the race
issue in our country we can't talk about
systemic racism without talking about
systemic misogyny I don't want to make
that a thing maybe it's stupid I don't
know but I think that it's parallel I
think there's a parallel feeling that I
think that we should you know just
discuss as a you know as a country I
think we should discuss it within your
family I think you should just you know
just discuss it about just thinking
about how our behavior affects other
people you know and then I think that
once we do that I think that will come
out the other side better for it so
anyways like I say I have a great
discussion with Rick Glassman I'll take
your shoes off about it and that's
really all I want to talk about with
this I don't even know I'm thinking
looking I'm not I'll look back on this
and be like did I even say anything I
think that I did I hope you understand
where I'm coming from you know it's
difficult because it's like you know
it's like when when all the headlines
are about like el la comedians or
terrible men and then you know I'm il a
comedian I'm a man so I'm like okay let
me look at that and be like you don't
you know it's not all of us you know I
think like I say it's case by case but I
think that you could look back at all
the cases enough times and be like I
probably shouldn't have said that
probably shouldn't have done that
probably shouldn't have sent that DM or
whatever it is that you've done in the
past or you know how you here trying to
interact with women with fans with
colleagues and as a man I think we
should be able to look back and be like
I got to do better
so that's what I'm gonna do I'm you know
just moving forward because even even if
it doesn't have to even be about
pursuing someone for us you know
pursuing someone sexually no just even
how you interact at just in general we
have to treat women better I mean that's
just really you know he sounds stupid to
say right like of course like duh right
but you know in the same way that like
you shouldn't hate people for what the
color of their skin is right duh but it
still happens you know cops are still
killing black people okay well men are
still treating women like [ __ ] so let's
do something about that let's make that
to discussion instead of it just being
some kind of witch hunt to like you know
destroy a guy okay
let's not just make it just about that I
mean I think we should use this
situation as a way to have a more
broader nuanced broader and nuanced
discussion both together about being
better human beings but that being said
now you can listen to this episode of
her flick riffin you know what's
coronavirus talk and just general race
relations talk but not and this was
actually before the George Floyd
situation blew up and I had with the
great Godfrey so I don't know if what I
just dis intro was I don't know I'm
really uncomfortable and I mean you
could probably tell it makes me
uncomfortable to talk about this because
you know it's layered issue it's like I
don't want to seem like I don't want to
throw my friend under the bus but at the
same time I'm not gonna act like ice
condone bad behavior that's not what it
is you know it's not that at all either
you know I'm disappointed when you see
the everything together you just go oh
man maybe you shouldn't have said that
to this person maybe you shouldn't have
done that so that's why I made it about
me but you know here we are let's let's
get better from this you know I think
that should be the lesson I think that
let's start having more discussions I
think men should talk to other men
be like yo dude have you ever done this
you know you know like have you ever
been in a situation like this have you
ever like you know and ask yourself and
ask each other like hey how could we do
better and I think that would be the
first step you know but listen to these
stories and you know so I commend all
the ladies out there that are coming out
with their stories and their and their
saying this is how I felt and I think
it's important to say that stuff I think
it's important to be like this made me
feel this way regardless if it was my
intent or any man's intent to make you
feel that way I think it's important for
you to be like hey but it made me feel
this way cuz then if the guy can look
back and be like oh you know what I see
how I see that now I see that it made
you feel uncomfortable or it made you
feel whatever the feeling that you're
feeling so but anyways alright whatever
there it is I I did my best
or I probably didn't do my best but I
just wanted it to be raw unfiltered here
it is uncut these are my feelings about
some of the things that have been going
on but anyway please enjoy this episode
and I'll see you next week on riffing
with Griffin ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the show away from a Griffin
longtime friend mr. Godfrey are you know
you're doing good either
it either stands for example or it
stands for Eric Griffin what's going on
I see you doing good to your right you
got you you in the bar area oh yeah
you know what that's so funny you stole
right dude no matter what's in that
could be apple juice in there people
like damn costly ball right now and I
hold it like this you guys don't know
I'm doing well yeah I got a couple
things I mean mister you're in New York
right now right I'm in new and why baby
yes
Disease Control yeah do like huh I mean
this how's it been going man Andy you
know what I want to talk to you about
even specifically because I was on this
show with all things comedy and it was
just called the Minority Report and they
were just I mean you look at these
figures and numbers worse like it seems
like black and Latino people are dying
way more from coronavirus did anyone
else well at first through sickle-cell
like what's going on you know it was we
were immune to remember we weren't it
was like it's not it doesn't seem to
affect the blacks give us some time
we're gonna be the leading dyers of this
whole [ __ ] watch because they love to
change the narrative racially a lot of
times in the news because a lot of times
I feel I don't know if you feel this way
it's always some kind of way our fault
no matter what the [ __ ] happens it's
always our fault like something happens
like they blame they were blaming Asians
right because it started in China
whatever I think it started in China on
some real real [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't think
it was no Betty somebody bats but it was
on some if you're into that heavier
heavier [ __ ] I'm not gonna I don't know
what your kind of podcast is like
managed to do it this is all it's called
riffing with Griffin so if you are us
conspiracy theorist or if you have a
thing in your head about I'm all for
listening it's not even a conspiracy I
just know the [ __ ] was created period so
it was created because my thing is Bill
Gates had a TED talk some years ago
talking about depopulation depopulating
depopulation virus he just kept talking
about it I was like yeah and and and he
funds a lot of Shimon his foundation and
a lot of other [ __ ] they they
put money into this [ __ ] and and it's no
different than Tuskegee Experiment
Native Americans were purposely injected
with [ __ ] to die off I mean this is no
different I mean I'm not trying I'm just
looking at basic knowledge like really
there's a virus and then it's spread it
upwards but it's kind of well you know I
I'm not necessarily as heavy on the
you are let's say you're at a ten maybe
I'm at like a seven and but cuz because
think about it as weirdest you just look
at like at first it was like oh it
doesn't affect children running and it
kills older people and people with like
something's wrong with them already so
they're already like you know they're
already like doing [ __ ] to the medical
system they're a burden like it's like
getting rid of like the people that are
burden to the medical field they got rid
of them but making sure kids are okay so
if you're if what I'm saying is if
you're a conspiracy theorist you have
you could be like link and and and and i
think most crib decently smart people
when you start going like this wait a
minute yes your brain going yo there's
something wrong though like wait wait
you just said old people there's you
don't I mean there's I can't when you
critically think about [ __ ] does don't
just believe whatever the [ __ ] you know
you when it comes to our government
telling us [ __ ] and there's been their
history of just you know the history I'm
not saying they've always been like that
but there's a lot of history of a lot of
[ __ ] read that they've done enough oh
here we go again with this [ __ ] you
know gen-i what is it and I don't watch
the news on purpose I'm not even [ __ ]
with the news cuz they their thing is
about sensationalizing thing and I know
people who work for seeing and I know
people who work on the news and they'll
tell me this [ __ ] like they are gonna
pick the stories they want they're gonna
pick the [ __ ] it's all about controlling
and controlling the narrative and
controlling the reactions and emotions
of people and this virus is real it's
real as [ __ ] yeah but as far as it just
popping out of nowhere I mean we have
viruses we have flus we have that [ __ ]
that's the fact we have bacteria in our
bodies that are in our bodies but I but
as far as like when some people are
talking about you know you heard of
eugenics getting rid of people like I
read some whole thing and it's all
coming out on it at social
they got one where you know the lady
from Planned Parenthood the lady same
the lady who created Planned Parenthood
she was a eugenics freak about
depopulating people and then Bill Gates
and and and and his dad was on the board
of the Planned Parenthood it's it's all
there and and I'm the guy who created
IBM was part of eugenics and then Bill
Gates was on the board of ivic so
they're all into this whole [ __ ] and
funding all this [ __ ] though it's
like what do you and Bill Gates is just
trying to push this vaccine you're not a
[ __ ] doctor fro you dropped out of
college and became you know my Christie
came a computer genius but you got so
much money that you can actually fun
horrible [ __ ] like this you know what I
mean that's right it's just like totally
I totally understand you know it's like
you know I get it I mean I just watched
this son Neff they had a new first of
all I take every documentary we had a
grain of salt now because you want to
talk about pushing a narrative that's
what a documentary is a documentary it's
like they they pick a subject they pick
a point and the whole documentaries
trying to prove that point as opposed to
like like here's some information I want
to get out there so doc but anyway they
just had this new one about you know the
the corona virus but one of the things I
found interesting in it was like they
were talking about h1n1 and they're
saying like the chicken flu don't affect
humans the human flu don't affect
chickens but when they get near a pig
the pig makes it so and I think to
myself we're the problems regardless
because only we bring chickens and pigs
together like when with chickens and
pigs ever be [ __ ] with each other you
know what I mean you know what
Charlotte's Web I mean even that so I
feel like you know we think about farms
and we think about farms it's like some
you know middle of America like like
farms are where it's at and this is how
you know and then you go well maybe
that's not a good thing maybe we're not
supposed to be bringing animals that are
like don't normally [ __ ] with each other
together
man [ __ ] with nature ma'am yeah okay
the fact that we're all inside the earth
is cleaned up I heard there's like the
ozone what some part of the earth where
the air was of life on opening and ozone
s it's closed up it's like me dude I
feel like I know he's that good you're
saying not to cut you off but just to
step on with that I just wanna say I
feel like I feel like what we've proven
is like every week every year for one
week maybe two weeks the whole world
should shut down we just go we should
have an earth bread a Earth Day like
it's like an Earth Week yeah like where
it's like we shut down just shut down
earth break we have an earthquake a
[ __ ] siesta from evil
good lord you know the other day not too
long ago they had Earth Day you know
that George Carlin bit about Earth Day
Earth you some plastic bags are gonna
cure give me a [ __ ] great you don't
mean these environments are pieces of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you the earth has been around
for billions of years he said the earth
is going nowhere we are why my
girlfriend's cousin works at a recycling
he worked he works me makes recycling
equipment it like these these big
machines they're million-dollar machines
right but then you start talking to
people in the recycling business and you
find out that it's all [ __ ] like you
know like the whole thing's [ __ ]
like wherever you think that bloop in
like when you put [ __ ] in that blue bin
and you think that [ __ ] is going to some
places help in the world you are a
[ __ ] idiot but it's like but that you
know what it is it's the dog and pony
show you know what it's like it's like
when you go to the airport and like TSA
is a dog and pony show okay so that's
just to make us feel like hey take your
shoes off let you know like what like
you know me like how many how many
terrorists are you catching at the
airport in a year do you treat me the
paying customer like this like how many
you really catch you somos a
dog-and-pony show to make me well okay
we're safe we're safe and that's what
that is
when I was [ __ ] like in like these
environmental nut bags are like when
they're like put your things in the blue
bin and that's for them to go like I'm
doing my part but you don't know where
it goes from there you're not checking
up yeah that's what's so great about I
guess being the powers that be we don't
know what they're doing a majority of
the time that's the part where they go
you see stuff on the news let's think
about like as actors as comedians yeah
and let's say you know you shot a
special you shot an hour and seven an
hour and 50 minutes special they saw 45
minutes yeah they did a lot of [ __ ]
there's no editing as a [ __ ] and
that's what they must hear when they
like like here's example when they show
Donald Trump coming from a big trap he
went to Sweden for a thing and they'll
show they'll show all day that Donald
Trump was in Sweden for a big important
meeting and they'll show that same
footage of him coming off the airplane
it's the same footage it's the same all
day Donald Trump has been off to about
8:00 any other different activities
during all this time he's probably doing
a whole bunch of other [ __ ] while they
keep showing his Donald Trump that's
coming to Sweden they show it over and
over and hail can we follow down with
Trump on what hit that [ __ ] was
doing this we did not you just know he
was in Sweden and then they show and
then we then we fill our brain fills in
like well he's the president he must be
doing something important that's the
part that they like guys know the rest
it's like when in a movie they don't
really have to show up they don't have
to show nudity in a movie and close the
door we know you guys is [ __ ] dude you
took man we think alike because you know
what I was thinking in my head remember
the movie 7 remember 7 yes wait check it
out they never showed who they never
show the actual killing they only showed
the result and your mind filled in how
horrible it must have been that's how
such a great movie it was you're a
[ __ ] up like the gory with it they
would say it was psychological thriller
yeah so I think it's like you know
speaking of the news like you were
talking about
you know what's weird to me is like so
the news can be then the news they they
control the narrative and then it's also
politicized so then depending on where
you watch like I've said this before
like it's so I like to watch both so
I'll turn on box but I want to see where
they're at so you turn on Fox and they
have all these people telling you that
this quarantine is gonna be worse than
their actual corner virus and all the
effects of quarantine on poverty and and
and and psychological effects and people
will be depressed and all this stuff
right then you turn on CNN and they act
like we're all gonna die you know so
it's like I don't know I'm like yo can
we get together like if this is so
important so to me let me tell you one
thing I've learned about the corona
virus it's not important enough to bring
people together yet you know it's not
like Ebola if like if like half the
White House staff died today like it's
just like someday you know whatever
disease came in and we would be acting a
lot different you know it'll be a summit
all the news people would be like
getting the right information now but
the other virus still it I don't it
don't feel dangerous enough to make
people actually come together and make
sure that we're doing right that's my my
comedian opinion you know I mean my
humble opinion because we're comedians
but we live in this planet and we're
affected too you know you know we see
the world through comedic eyes but we
still have to humanize this [ __ ] like oh
[ __ ] you don't mean and our language is
comedy so we're gonna speak in their
language there's some songwriters right
now write the songs about the [ __ ]
there's somebody painting about the [ __ ]
so you know we're gonna come at our
perspective regardless of what out
people [ __ ] think we're gonna say
what we say in our comedic way you know
but there's some comedians that dig into
this kind of [ __ ] really dig into this
and some that just take it for service
value and go ah I don't watch the news
Fox they'll see it in all of them
they're all full of [ __ ] and I believe
it's a back and forth day there's some
truth and there's some false [ __ ] but
sensationalization really pumping up the
fear fears what keeps people under
control fear - fear of anything how do
you think past
money church religion they go hey watch
out
better put money in that thing oh you're
not gonna reap what you sow lord have
mercy
we need 10% tithing people putting money
or fear that they're not gonna get a
blessing you know
yeah yeah right you're right yeah I'm
here just saying think about that think
about the world of Health and the
workout [ __ ] billion dollar industry
because fear of dying fear of not being
in shape fear of not having good health
come on if this video you're not you're
lonely it's it's the fear fear sells man
what about the makeup industry
insecurity it's it's based off
insecurity you better get these lashes
or you won't look good it's a fear thing
it's fear makes money men you know I
mean fear is a very wonderful tool
psychological things you better get this
or this is not gonna happen
better no you know they definitely do
and different levels of fear not like
everyone's like yeah but whether it's
medical they could do that yeah you know
how they would do as growing up they
would always change what causes cancer
it was like you drink milk
it can cause blah blah blah that's you
an art dude in our era especially where
we came up it was like it was always
they that my mom was always they say you
didn't gotta eat broccoli
you know a new body shows and the
experts say and Owen in over like this
scientists at Harvard University came up
with that roasted flakes actually gives
you better respiratory abilities and I
think they stir around I think I think I
think news writers are literally like
comedians like what should I talk about
today yeah they must be well but then
but is that a and then the people the
news I'm like no that's a good one yeah
yeah it's like the SNL writers room yeah
but unfortunately but then you know when
you have a 24-hour news cycle and you
have to fill it up and then like there's
a fine line between news and
entertainment it seems like you know so
you have news information and
entertainment and it seems like they
found a way to like combine all those
things you know see what they do is very
smart they go this just did oh [ __ ]
that god I said we got it what happened
oh man what's wrong right
that is like and now whether sports and
entertainment it's like they emotionally
it's just chronologically I'm set up so
perfectly to [ __ ] it's a mind [ __ ] bro
it's like wow I'm glad we can end with
good news a puppy drive they just saves
a couple puppies come and buy some
puppies after the first one was a man
got stabbed in the [ __ ] eye
yeah I mean it's like that is what it's
it's it's done on purpose it's like but
then I always knew the news at some
point was [ __ ] too sometimes because
there are real journalists out there I'm
not gonna sit there and say all the news
there are real journal but the news when
you see when you when you watch a news
show and commercials come on come on man
yeah I know that's how I feel the
Cheerios B is on I just watched it
killing as Cheerios whoa it's ad dollars
think about the people that are that are
that the reason why this shit's art is
because the ad dollars so you think
about it if it's daytime and you're
watching the news you're gonna see a lot
of diaper commercials you're gonna see a
lot of household products because a lot
of housewives are probably home right
then it when night comes you go the new
Cadillac 20/20
drop because because supposedly the debt
people who drive cars are home now back
work well why should you get a new car
it's all set up it's a genius idea and
it's the ad dollars are ones that
provides you with the news they'll be
like CNN provided by prudential or this
is
they're like and if I have money right I
got money
and I'm putting your [ __ ] on I'ma be
like eh you want
I need my product sold yo so when are
you throwing us in when he's joining
soon okay cool cool cool after the what
after the dude gets stabbed in the neck
okay
after the puppy threat right before the
puppy draft thanks yeah man it's crazy
like you know you know so much like like
what you're talking about right now is
how I feel like like let's the left news
like CNN MSNBC they for some reason they
get off on showing us whoever the
youngest person that died of coronavirus
it's like it's their job to be like oh
my god a 14 year old died of coronavirus
and then and then why like just per
capita just like if you just go like
just the street almost 400 million
people in the United States and you look
at the numbers of people that have died
you go like okay I don't want anybody to
die obviously but like to this kind of
fear-mongering of like this guy died so
that means we all can die it's like how
about how about show me for every one
person that has died that we don't think
and die of coronavirus how about you
show me a thousand people that are
walking out of the hospital that did
have it why would they do that they
never show they could I would love that
it'd be like here's a John Smith from a
Brooklyn had Corona and now he's okay
and then you know like they want to
happen look he's just he's just waving I
have an immune boost and I'm good now
like they never show those people it's
always the worst possible story because
they're like okay what are the ratings
okay how are we gonna keep these
[ __ ] turning on channel keep
them [ __ ] in their past what's who do
they say now it's you know I mean we we
don't want to be cynical right it's hard
not to be cynical because I would like
to think the sentiment is hey we should
really keep the quarantine going because
look at these people that have died
they're just like you you know it's like
hey we'd be careful but they they
present it in a way that I don't think
that's what it is
you wanna you know you know to me you
think that's what it is and I'm sure
there are some people like that I'm sure
there's like you said there's great news
people there's people that have
integrity and they're and they're trying
to get a good story out because it's
supposed to be the fourth branch of
government you know information is
supposed to be the fourth branch of
government getting it to the people you
know but you know it's just completely
controlled you know you start to you
blow your mind when you start to go
there's a board of people who are really
really rich that control the news and
you're just gonna walk how is that you
know how is this how is it a thing it
shouldn't it be public you know
shouldn't hit on I mean I don't know
it's crazy
yeah it's and and the people that
control everything do not look like us
it's like it's not even hard to figure
that out
oh I wonder who's running this I would
love to blame it on people that look
like us but you know just the way the
system is they wouldn't even dare give
us that kind of power and at the same
time don't when's the last time you
turned on BT news oh I remember BT news
says Jackie read was BT news and I know
her now she used to be BT knows they're
using me of eet news I know they used to
be like a black but it like where's the
black news and do we want to watch it
will bit like do you don't you feel like
we like just being honest will still
have contempt you know what I mean like
we're just sort of the bees you know
like what they talk about on BT news but
it's the same reason why it's the same
reason why minorities don't don't look
for their award shows in the same light
as they look for the white award shows
you know it's like the the Image Awards
should be just as prestigious as the
Emmys Oscars and Golden Globes but we
know we don't you know what I mean like
jay-z showed up late for the source
Awards
you don't mean he's a CP Awards he if it
was just the Image Awards but yeah yeah
yeah ee CP you might as well have the
snick oscars the snake oscars the core
you know what
it's like it's like Community College
you know it was upon us and I feel like
I feel like all the envelopes you know
it is like the end oh and I'm not
putting down that image award but it's
it's it's like there's this thing like
the image awards n-double-a-cp image
sounds like oh yeah let's give them an
award thing and double-a-c-p
right that's and that's not me change
that how do we flip that you know flip
it to having we should get our own award
show we do have our own award show named
after somebody really famous we should
have our own [ __ ] because it turned out
check it out the Country Music Awards is
really big you know like the Country
Music Award is Hugh it's a it's a
prestigious thing but it's not all but
it's not it's predominantly white well
it's not you know it doesn't actually
all the things that we call white
they're not labeled white it's just like
it's just it's because of all the other
things that like when you you yes
default yeah default like like there's
here's a really good book I would like
you all to try and read it is fantastic
dog it's called it's backwards white
fragility it won't be back it's not
backwards just for you it is white
fragility and it's by Robin to vote on a
white woman it is when I said it's up to
date it's the new fat it is real and my
friend gave me this [ __ ] it talks about
all that white fragility about she's so
honest and she even says like I don't
have to worry
um I don't have to worry about like Ray
see like I was born into a culture in
which I belonged racially indeed the
forces of racism were shaping me even
before I took my first breath if I I was
born in a hospital regardless of the
decade I was born in any hospital would
be open to me because my parents were
white if my parents attended the
childbirth preparation class the
instructor was most likely white the
videos they watched in class most
lightly depicted white people and their
fellow classmates with whom they built
connections and community were also most
likely white when my parents read their
birthing manuals and other written
materials the pictures most likely
depicted primarily white mothers and
fathers doctors and nurses if they took
their parenting class the theories and
models of child development were based
on white racial identity the doctors and
nurses attended my birth but that
attended my birth were all in all
likelihood white although my parents may
have been anxious about the birth
process they didn't have to worry about
how they would be treated by the
hospital staff because of their race hey
Mike she's so dumb it's his soul when I
tell you this [ __ ] is fire and it's only
when a white person is honest that way
and it's it's just a it's sometimes a
better perspective because you're so
used to reading books of you know Toni
Morrison the James bought it so yeah
yeah you know their perspective too you
know when it's a when it's a white when
it's a black you know political radical
you you know that this is their
perspective and you're reading it like
that you know even if you're a non-white
if you if your white brows are you
reading then you're going like oh you're
trying to like commiserate you're trying
to like have empathy as opposed to
somebody white just being like here's
hey this is what this is my reality yeah
that's the reality and it's so good it's
like they're the default when it when
it's like when I see um when I saw the
history of comedy at CNN I was like what
the [ __ ] is this like because how many
everybody was white I was like the
[ __ ] are you serious right now I was
like first of all first of all the
Masters and the legends of comedy I'm
not taking nothing from the Don Rickles
the Milton Berle's nothing but the
mother [ __ ] is that people repeat out
their mouths are black
like from Eddie from Bill Cosby from
Redd Foxx from I mean you know you know
say Richard Pryor
like I'm see I'm you know in order I
mean we got Harlan who's the mm of it
[Laughter]
it's like why are you not including us
but the default for comedy is is white
and it's then that's not it that's not
the true it's not the true because not
to be and you being that you know even
being a comedian for clear let's this be
real them stages are rocked by us
we're the ones rocking them [ __ ] and
I'm not taking anything from white
people and white there are a lot of
funny people on every race but come on
now
there-there's reasons why they put us in
the end of the [ __ ] line up in April
and there's reasons why a lot of white
comments ago oh can I go before you oh
can I go you know and we are never
complaining because we're used to being
put in the end it's like it's like
comedy is like a [ __ ] bus we're
always putting up and putting the backs
in the back you know I mean but I'm it
is it's the reality of it you know and
me and you have been have been fortunate
to be able to do we can do mainstream
and we get chosen for a lot of
mainstream [ __ ] and all that you know
neither disparity you still see that the
[ __ ] that goes on like really guys
like you know it was that's why it was
so hard it was like I I had a problem
during the me to movement yes being
lumped in just because I'm a guy you
know like being a man was like you know
you look at the lineup because it
because it was a lot of this going on
tweeting at the lineups that you're on
right sit economy store had they put up
the lineup somebody's tweeting at it oh
nice all man again are no women on the
lineup you know and I'm like hey take
another look it's still mostly white
like don't like you know like you still
want to take away from like all the
struggles that people have done like cuz
where does it end like where's that I
could you know cuz in you know the you
know Brad Williams is the only dwarf he
could be out there like you know where a
Dwarfs on the lineup you know whoever's
Asian and whoever is like you know it
could get
goes on and on but I just kind of feel
like you know unfortunately comedy it's
just you you would like to me I wish
comedy was just a level playing field
yeah
it's just you know but it's not but at
the same time though I don't want to
like come across like a victim it's not
a victim Society say that about you
either but no but this is what I'm
saying those like because this is
something I've learned about comedy in
the last five years you know that like I
come from an old-school era where I
thought just being funny was enough you
know you know you come over this thing
we saw these but what we deal what it is
is because there was no social media
back then so we didn't know the hustle
that was going on behind the scenes for
those comics that we look up to all the
things that they had to do to get where
they went but it's it's more to it it's
about it's about fashion too it's about
you know style it's about you know
connecting with your fans and
personality and like and what would you
come to find out is when you start to
check off they're important on the list
funny ain't even at the top of the list
it's not at the top of the list funny is
not selling out theaters it's not it's
that you know it's it's it's that
charisma it's that like you know it's
all these other things and it's like I
just wish I would have realized those
things I wish I would have thought about
it more like that coming up you know in
general but you know I know doesn't work
that way you you you you live in the
present it's like somebody it's like
you're you're a coach and you see a
bunch of players and there's one that
sucks and they don't make the team
because they didn't updated they weren't
able to accomplish the things that you
made it to see and then they end up
being great later on how the [ __ ] were
you supposed to know you were living in
a present they sucked and they don't
play and and that's the thing aborts
it's so fair it's like if you suck right
now you can't play meritocracy man
meritocracy I love it right I love
meritocracy and the thing about us is we
grew up watching funny [ __ ] on
TV we're like oh that we get why they're
famous they're [ __ ] funny
like yeah we do yeah Carol Burnett and
her crew yeah oh yeah Flip Wilson yeah
Oh Redd Foxx after decide yeah we they
were funny they were funny like
all of the family yeah anyone Emmys like
yeah agreed
used to that we were used to that like
when we watched our faith know dance I
wasn't it yeah he's [ __ ] great DeNiro
fantastic I don't and there's no
discrepancy that but this is the own
business I think entertainment where you
can literally you can literally reward
mediocrity you can just horrible but
guess what we're gonna do for you they
can built because sometimes and I don't
know everybody this is just basic you
know being in the business sometimes
some people that run certain things have
them through a position and they'll see
a person that reminds them of them
they'll bring their personal [ __ ] to the
job like that person reminds me of me
when I was bullied I'm gonna give him
the job and the person and talent
reminds me of a god I used to beat up on
me
really you're bringing that to the
[ __ ] state who's doing the job
who's doing the good job here I'm and
like you said there is a marketing
aspect to it some people are even if
they're talented they're just there's
there's a marketing thing to it there's
a style there's a look of course but we
all realize that because later on
because my managers like get on stage be
as good as you can [ __ ] kill that
[ __ ] and her and as a comedian and you
know oh this was like the first time
that comedy got a little bit compromised
it got it but it didn't really do much
like people that were doing sketches on
instagram that are in the millions and
flowers they're doing theaters not it
yeah you know this is the first time we
were able to put kind of put the cart
before the horse as far as comedy life
you see these [ __ ] going on
stage calling themselves comedians and
they are far from it and they go on
stage and they're and you go to a improv
and somebody go hold did you see a sock
puppet Pete was here who sock puppet be
I'd like to call a sock puppet Pete
that's my Instagram are you putting are
just put country in the name
[Laughter]
sock puppet country Pete just something
like I mean I just don't get me started
but let me wait I'm sorry but it's wrong
you hear that you go yeah he sold out
the burger and then I go how was he how
was she oh it was garbage but that's
what they the beautiful thing about
comedy is there it was just a small dent
with social media just a small death
because this dis dis art crap this crap
you can't skip you can't sir
but or is it okay here's the thing
though real quick okay I was about to
say there's a there's I can I agree and
I disagree well I mean I you know what
though I I don't know if I agree because
what we're finding out is your agent
they're not called comedy agents they're
not called stand-up agents what are they
called ages now they called public
appearance agents right that's your PA
they're called PA agents they're not
called comedy agents they're not called
you know a great standup you know
organizers you know they're not you know
it's like it's like math it's like a
used car salesman you know what you're
getting you're getting a used car okay
all right so PA agent it's called public
appearance and what I've come to accept
is that's what that is
listen man there's dudes out there with
millions of followers on Facebook
Twitter Instagram and they just go
they're just doing a public appearance
for their fans hmm and unfortunately
they're doing it in comedy clubs and
they're doing it in like but it's
because comedy clubs are set up to hold
a lot of people so that's all that this
is and so I stopped bringing about it
then in that way I stopped going like
what did it guys not funny why is I got
no no they don't know it doesn't matter
they need somebody to fill up this
building and sell drinks and his fans
want to come and check it out these
people know this person isn't funny
because they're not coming for that
they're coming because oh it's - dude
that's on my screen that does the accent
with the wig on or his to do is stop
[ __ ] stop it Pete is here and you
know and they I don't know they they in
the lobby like buying the puppet and
they're like oh can we take a picture
can we you know to me and they put their
hands in the puppet and they standing
next to sock puppet Pete and they do it
like I call my guys sock puppet Johnny
and then they like you know I mean
that's what it is dude
so like you know so the problem is it's
like here's a problem it would be like
if there was another sport that looked
like basketball you know it looked like
it and they needed a place to play and
in the NBA arenas was like well yeah
come play here and then some of the NBA
teams like well we we had to cancel our
Thursday game because you know what you
know sock puppet trying to jam that down
our throats right oh yeah you know some
people I'm not even I'm not even ashamed
of it
I like listen I like a lot of women
sports all right I like women's
volleyball
I think it's compelling that's a whole
other reason but I like it's really
compelling I think women's about bat
volleyball should be a pro sport
nationally so you know because it's dope
it's a slam dunk every play it's a
touchdown every play it's really
exciting and it you know I love that and
also it's comparable to the men's sport
and what I mean by that is the speed of
it the speed and agility and athleticism
I don't like women's basketball the [ __ ]
looks low it looks you know to me I just
it look it looks slow it is late and
then they I don't like the outfit
it don't do nothing for that's the dumb
man part but I'm just saying it again
sweaty in the house there's no dunks
there's no I'm saying the highest level
of the sport is men okay it just is
because it's just you LeBron James you
know these super athletic we did a
physical physical freaks of nature and
then they're going up and down the court
faster jumping high so I want to see
something close to that so like that's
why women's soccer is great because it
still looks like soccer
you know women's hockey it's great it
still looks like hockey tennis even I
love first of all I think women's tennis
is better than men's tennis because
because the lack of athleticism makes it
more competitive because sometimes men's
tennis is like serve serve you know I
mean it's like these powerful serves and
they don't even get to but women's
tennis would be like cuckoo cacao you'd
only like it anyway at disti we got off
subject but I'm just saying like I have
no problems bashing women's basketball
and those women Beth and those women
basketball players I'm not gonna play
you one-on-one you gonna be better than
me I'm talking as a fan all right as a
fan of basketball that [ __ ] is not
entertaining just lower the rims make
them shits eight-foot and I want to see
chicks like Duncan only children they
need to make the rim lower I'm just
saying dude I'm like I'm not against we
female sports I'm talking about how it
looks in comparison to like you know I
don't know it's just like you know it's
crazy but anyways
that like you know cuz I but you were
saying I totally agree with because I
remember when I was um a friend Jeff Eon
showed me he runs from the Dallas Improv
in Addison and he was he went and we
went backstage and when he was just
breaking down the business to me just
breaking it down cuz he was talking
about other comedians complaining how
come I'm not here how come you don't
book me and EJ showed me figures hey he
said let me show you overhead real quick
general of a comedy club real quick yeah
I mean he will be bound to me I never
ever ever complained I was like I
[ __ ] get it but I kind of figured
that out yeah but he said what
understand comedy is the last thing we
are bar and grill we are trying to sell
all this [ __ ] we paid for all that food
we paid for all that though liquor we're
trying to give them credit is [ __ ] we
need to make our money back from that
now we're talking about that now you're
talking about maintenance of the kitchen
now you talk about maintenance of lights
maintenance of the spot now we're
talking about employees that we got a
fake there's that then there man and
when he broke all that [ __ ] down and he
go now we bring the comedian it now
that's why and then and that's why
country Pete is gonna be here next week
because he already sold out eight shows
and we go okay let's look at our comic
list who is the who's who are the big
names that are gonna help us cut down on
this cause
ok BAM we can charge him this we're
gonna make that so now we've made up all
our money for this this is that who's
right under that we got tears we got
levels of Tears yeah now we made all
this money we got all this money we've
made now we can put in people we don't
really know he would act weak that can
we can build on them because we can
afford the loss we like or people we
like but they just don't sell out they
just don't sell out and there's some
people that just we just like the
[ __ ] now we're gonna squeeze
them cuz we just like being around that
person and you know what they might be
able to build but we'll take a chance on
them and then what people to understand
is that's why a lot of comments are
afraid to headline because they don't
want to see a half-empty
stuff and stuff you know they're killing
it in New York but when they go to Idaho
or Iowa
and they gotta make an excuse to say yo
man
tickets are low because there's a parade
down the street we have a big a big we
have a big annual um don't go to the
comedy club parade so that's probably
what destroyed your whole [ __ ] but way
better snow and there's an earthquake
tomorrow so more than likely people
gonna want ill but it there's levels to
headlining and I understand when on
these Instagram people come in with 4
million 5 million followers and they
pack rules I go they're gonna take them
first because they're paying the light
bill they're paying they're paying that
bill but but here's where guys like me
and you that are we're doing we're
headlining and other people this is
where we win because the notoriety that
they're getting from being on their
sketches which I don't knock their
hustle I think they're great at this
[ __ ] but the time that you have to put
in the standup never changes yes should
be on that [ __ ] stage well all
the time well here's what's happening is
the purest art form and there's gonna
catch up to them and people gonna keep
it and the dumb but numbers like they
get but again but here's what's gonna
happen
alright this is what I think it's
already happening you know ok so
remember when all those actors who are
just actors they're agents were like you
know you can make like 10 grand a
weekend if you go do start to a stand-up
ok so you know what you're doing now
podcasts to do in podcast yeah they
found a way to like those people that
are doing sketches they found a way to
monetize that so they're like I don't
want to go to Idaho you know they're
like where you want me to go uh how long
am I gonna be there they're starting to
go why I just made a hundred thousand
dollars on YouTube and my thing my
merged business is going well so what's
happened is it's not just that the the
extent of comedy game is catching up to
them what's catching up to them is like
cuz they're like I don't want to put
this work in because
I don't need to now that's a ketchup
that's what I'm saying they're like oh
you know you got that's what I mean what
if you're explaining in a different way
that's what I mean that they'll be like
hey you got to go on the road whoa whoa
what oh no I'm gonna do that [ __ ] and so
they're switching the game up maybe
podcasting maybe I know but even
podcasting me didn't even even with
podcasting man there's a couple
podcasting bro
just yeah yeah I know I know I know but
what's what also is still happening too
is like there are people with big
podcasts who are those if you don't have
a huge following now then they go out
with your huge following and they're
filling up places too from Instagram
because Joe Rogan Marc Maron the the
bill Burt they're all comic they're all
yeah yeah yeah you people with the
biggest pop podcast are experienced
folks whether they're writers
journalists whatever they've had they
put their time in through experience not
through a phone not do that you tell me
what [ __ ] I'll tell you you'd be
surprised what I'm saying is we don't
what what I'm saying is that you you'd
be surprised like you know it's like
those kids from I don't even think
they're kids anymore but the guys from
wildin out they have that 405 South
they're actually some are actually like
Carlos Miller no no I know but I'm
saying is like if what I'm saying is
here's an example of people who like
we're gonna start doing comedy they were
doing comedy desktop their dream then
they took the notoriety from one thing
combining with this new medium and now
they out here doing theaters and stuff
like so it worked so so I'm saying it's
like there's still an accelerated
process now it's different
see that's the difference now is I you
know we come from an era of light you do
all that mic so you do all this stuff
and like you know and then you get past
it well that's a big club and the day
it's like [ __ ] all that
like that's just got the door it's like
there's other ways now like the open mic
now is your podcast and then talking
every week and writing jokes and maybe
you do you're doing real shows now to
like prepare for a bigger things it's
just a different Road it's all I'm
saying
world but you you still gotta face the
beast man and a lot of people and I know
guys that have done shows with these
properties these Instagram people that
are that are selling out shows and they
go whoo deal and then and then they'll
put like comedians on that are
experienced and they get a hot they got
a hot 50 minutes of to to to comics come
in front of them and give them to
[ __ ] hot 25 minutes and they gotta
follow that [ __ ] and I said oh it's a
lot of them it is bad yeah that's why
they don't that's why they're just gonna
just have their own shows now they just
gonna bring you no no I I think that the
art of I agree with you the art of
economy is not gonna change what's
happened is the business has passed it
you know business is the business is
passed by it the business doesn't care
about it the business doesn't nurture it
the business is it's a business in us
and that's to think that you know I'm
catching up with you know it's like I
started this podcast because you know
just from my experiences of being on
other people's podcast and seeing if
affect the numbers you know and I was
like oh [ __ ]
and then it's like also it's like you
know you know you're one away from your
fans I love talking to my fans now I
love like being like you know
interacting with people like you know
some you know it it makes it also I
think it makes a comedy community like
commune more it's like when's the last
time we've been on the phone for an hour
you know I mean you know I mean I say we
don't you know so this is what I'm
saying so it's like there's other I just
say it's a different form of business
and we're trying to get there I was
talking from comedy as an art or period
I know work it's a curious thing if
someone labels themselves a comedian
which I think they a lot of them should
they make the mistake they should say
hey I'm a public appearance guy I'm it's
a public bigger boom I get it but when
you label yourself with comedian people
and then you go up there they're gonna
be like the art form has to kick it here
but check this out though but check this
out that's like a mistake that like it's
just a bad branding for the people who
are pure of comedy because like how many
times have like you know a person's been
on a reality show
and in a day doing public appearances
that's how they call it they say like oh
man I'm you know I was on such a such
show you now I'm getting thirty thousand
to show up at a club now you know to go
be a DJ now and like you know they're
you know it's just public appearance
stuff the problem is is that we're
calling it stand-up comedy because it
looks like it because somebody's
standing on the stage with a mic and
maybe they're being funny but even at a
even at like a lecturer somebody could
be funny you know it's like it still can
be funny because it's not expected
comedians wear it right but you know
people come in there like this no one
goes through electrical I mention
off-book bad meat rollin y'all know I
know you know I know he was off Rhona
but they got me some laughs in the
middle you know doctor foul cheese
coming but man I better be funny dog I
don't know who opened it Michael Eric
Dyson man you know when what a comedy
club people are like man this [ __ ]
better be funny or the expectation is
there because that's your job but I
almost feel that but I almost feel that
the problem with comedians and speaking
as a comedian is you know we get we've
we've been programmed to be pigeonholed
into a certain way of doing things and
it's almost like I think to myself I
said to my agent
like before all this started I said hey
maybe see if I can start doing some
lectures like see if I can go to like
colleges and like it's not about comedy
it's about like how to be an actor you
know how to audition how is it to be in
the business and I'll make it
entertaining because I'm funny so I'll
be able to move but like people have me
come because of that and say we I think
they're the the comedian's need to and
the ones that are doing it are like
these ones that are like you know
podcasting and really getting themselves
out there like selling out like you know
my agent said a month ago like this is
the hottest comedies been in a long time
in terms
selling tickets just hot there's people
out there who are like superstars now
that are not on television you know what
I mean they're doing a show here and
there but they're not famous for that
they're famous for them you know look at
like Burt like Bert Kreischer Chris
D'Elia you know there's these guys right
now who are like just like larger than
life because of their personalities and
then they back it up with like okay
here's what I've been working on here's
my stand-up and I just think it's like
it's amazing times I think we all need
to catch up too and I think they were
behind in some way sometimes I've got
the king batch with Reni deist all those
guys that that hustle and I give him
credit they're fine stars I got with
them I do stuff with them still I do see
that I love bad she's a funny remember I
caught I got off my assets that [ __ ] I'm
in with these [ __ ] because I
got the skills and I have the energy and
you know and so once I started doing
that I got my demographic changed yes
podcasting I got my own podcast and I
know your podcast by the way in Godfrey
we trust on gas digital network there's
my phone things and Fridays at 9:30 p.m.
Eastern it's really cool you can the ice
subscribe on it with promo code Godfrey
and it's Enix actually got free 30 and
it's free till May 15 so but yeah man
I'm a podcasting I'm doing that I'm on
other people's shows just like you and
now I'm glad you're doing it
[ __ ] all it you're from you know Comedy
Central people know you I think you
weren't funny through the route theories
like underrated as [ __ ] um I and and you
should be on you should be on you you're
not you're a [ __ ] nut dude you should
be on your smart dude you should be on
you should people should be like oh
[ __ ] Eric grab that dudes does you
should be interviewing all kinds of
people you should be present on these
[ __ ] platforms right that's what I'm
trying to do and I and I didn't realize
that I figure you know I I feel it
outlet better
late than never you know and you know
the mom but it's like I but I know it's
like but it's a I think it's just a
vicar victim of like you know cuz you're
in your forties right you know there's
so like we so when we were coming up it
was the tail end of you know whatever
was happening in the eighties nineties
like you know it's like coming off Chris
Tucker and death jam and and like all
that stuff and so that was when we were
like still trying to like find our way
and then comedies been stagnant it was
stagnant for many years and then got
reinvigorated again with like the
Internet man just the internet really
beautiful is like I go live every every
week every night for my 12:00 to 5:00
a.m. I go and but I've been I've been
even on the road two years ago twin
happier I was always going live you know
I said you know what I'm gonna do I'm
spending my hotel time online I'm gonna
set up my [ __ ] on the desk you know
those hotel - yeah yeah yeah and I would
go in the afternoon and be on there two
three hours just talking [ __ ] interview
what's up
then after I would finish my shows
sometimes I'd be in a green room talking
into it then I go back to my room get on
for another two three hours but I was
doing this for the longest so now with
the koban virus should I do it every
night and blood and a lot of my people
follow and my Nick my my my and now my
live I don't have an hour limit I go for
I they gave me a four hour stretch you
know what I mean and and you're in
people's faces and during COBIT I've had
will Packers see me in a Theon Crockett
do shake will Packer put toplin was was
communicated with Russell Simmons I
communicated with types of different
people you never know people are
watching everybody because no one has
people are home bro - said it best he
said man I'm up every day creating
everybody's like people are sleep right
now everybody got their guard down right
now yeah for us to Lee would be if
you're an idiot if you're not trying to
use these backwards right now you're a
[ __ ] idiot
because this might be the only thing
that there is wait
say I mean this might be the only thing
there is for the next four or five
months yeah unless you're you know
unless you're you know one of them
Superstars and don't need this [ __ ] like
the Brad Pitt's in the bucket rocks and
the butt or even though rock is the rock
is online ya know because everybody no
because everybody wants to commune
everybody wants to like interact
everybody wants to like you know this
reason why they you know they work all
the time because they want to be in
movies in like whatever that thing is
and so they might be missed at two no
matter who you are you know what I mean
so we're just out here and I've been
putting out extra content because I just
feel and you know what I really
appreciate is when I get these kind of
messages all the time I'm sure you do
too people go yo man I really appreciate
your channel because you know it's like
I just you know I've been I'm alone or
you know I just I've been bored or I'm
just depressed and you really keeping me
up and that kind of stuff and so you
know this is what we're doing right now
we just trying to like and you know and
I and I and I actually like actually
even when we get back to doing regular
[ __ ] I'm gonna do my podcast like this
because don't stop you know cuz I feel
like you know it is actually been okay
you know I mean like you know it looks
great and it's like you know I you know
real the thing is about cuz comedians we
always want to be able to run our own
game we've always wanted to be able to
call our own shots and and a lot of
times you know we audition for people
[ __ ] we're always auditioning for other
people writing for us sometimes you
can't even be free within a script you
cannot improv can you stick with the
script and you not do this not do that
and you're like damn you know so we're
always trying to fight for freedom and
this is what once you do your part
you'll be like now I feel like I'm I
feel like business more
business-oriented yeah I can monetize
this now I can do you it's the first
time I felt like a like a brand like
this is my brand this is my you you I'm
you get into a business mentality but we
did it we did it the other way right
yeah like and I'm saying like we used
Hollywood I'm saying we I'm saying we
did Hollywood because it was lucrative
you know I wanted to be on a TV show
because I always wanted to be on a TV
show but if I start to really think
about it it was because also the money
you know I mean you know and then it
wasn't till I started doing TV shows
that I was like there's no money in this
where's this money at you know this
nobody
where's the money you know to me feels
like you know you get these like weird
pay scales and stuff and I was like oh
[ __ ] you actually have to be like more
famous be like you know do they have to
be of a that you have to be on a show
where they can't make it without you
that's we're gonna make money you never
mean not being like the seventh lead so
you know then it
so this what's happened recently is we
found another way to to be to have a
lucrative business with what we do with
our personalities with our comedy with
our without you know what I mean with
that kind of stuff you know but anyways
hey man that's been our I just you know
IIIi appreciate you uh you know talking
I know we could talk for more but I
don't want you know you know people all
their attention spans are terrible but I
wanna have you on again like you know
you know as soon especially as long as
this is going on to see what's going on
but you know this is go free any any any
closing thoughts like I said just you
know like I said for us creative people
we are carrying the weight of the hours
that are open we are but I don't care
when you turn your podcast on when you
turn your lives on we are literally
getting people through this [ __ ] man
honestly and I think it would behoove
all creatives to use this platform I
don't give a [ __ ] don't feel bad about
numbers you see somebody with a hundred
thousand I'm gonna [ __ ] you see to
people you see eight people that's
important it's like when you perform on
stage are you gonna get offstage cuz
there's ten people in the room no you're
gonna go all out
right you're gonna do your thing you
don't know who the [ __ ] those 10 people
are waters about those five I don't want
to sound off point but it's real [ __ ] no
it is real [ __ ] I know I know he's that
cou you saying you never know and this
and this and here's another thing about
social media it's work it's not luck
thing really you have to do it all
it's like comedy you have you know stage
you got to get on phone
yeah you gotta do it consistently you
know who but you know who figured that
out before us was these social media
stars you know they figured it out
before us my crops I don't want anybody
to take this like I was [ __ ] on
anybody not at all I have learned from a
lot of yeah me too I've learned from
them and they're hustling and the one
thing I I saw about them that was
different than our school they all work
with each other they all they all trying
to go yo cuz I was at King matches house
this guys didn't one of nicest guys in
the world and he just and so innovated
he eats you know he's a film major -
yeah Canadian that's where that kindness
come true so he comes in you know people
in his room house they're shooting stuff
okay we're gonna shoot this guest bop
bop bop you go over there you shoot that
sketch let me boom are you ready I'll
switch everybody's just eating man
sharing just sharing dude yeah and
that's how my numbers went up you know
and ready is another guy that knows King
bash they hooked me up with you and we
just did we just shot and my numbers
went up and people and then a new never
new demographic opened up 17 year olds
15 year olds like yo yeah I know I got
off my ass and took the initiative I
said oh [ __ ] this I'm gonna start asking
I think my ego is out the way I said
[ __ ] and now I do my own sketches now
it's a habit for me I'm like I checked
my numbers it's it's part of me now
that's glad I'm glad it's a habit I'm
glad it's habit cuz it does change your
demographic it doesn't when I do bland
TV I start doing glad TV on YouTube
demographic change all of that [ __ ]
helps but you gotta be consistent you
gotta put it down I'm telling you take
it from me man you know I was I was at
8,000 followers like meters I meant
closing in on 400 thousand there you go
damn there it is right there so this is
just another example of following your
dream follow you you know learn how to
hustle
there's a hustle that everything takes
work you know sites yeah some people
have gone viral but but
you don't know all the things that they
did before then to prepare to get there
it's not just like over it's not it's
not overnight these people work hard
Tony Baker Tony Baker please work this
[ __ ] - Tony Baker who's one of social
such a funny comedian dad son of a [ __ ]
you talk about really changing and
really innovative in his videos that guy
took that [ __ ] by the reins man and he's
been on the podcast - man I got him on -
yeah by the way great I wish he was more
famous so people can he was more famous
people would appreciate that impression
even more totally Baker it's great and
he shares and comes out my [ __ ]
he enhances my [ __ ] we don't this is not
I'd be stressing this [ __ ] I talked to
kamau Bell today and I was talking I was
on his live and it and we our numbers
went up I said kemal starting to get on
it I said we all can enhance each other
those white boys I'm telling I'm telling
white boy dumb [ __ ] be looking
out for each other even if they don't
hug each other that money they're gonna
be they'll be damned that they don't
come together and rise up well I
stretching apart specially in a podcast
world you know what I mean I got I got
King making I got King makers in the
podcast world Chrysler Brian Cal they
look the [ __ ] out yeah we need to do the
same I don't get how to stress it we
need to cut out their dumb [ __ ] hey I'm
here I got you on I'm trying to I'm
trying to do it I said we all need to be
like DoCoMo for my ship need to do that
because we have the ability to do it we
have it it can build just like them we
can be kingmakers to [ __ ] yeah well you
heard your first man that's it right
there man I appreciate you man our pre
changing energy I appreciate what you're
doing you know always one of the
funniest guys around you know we love
going to jfl together the cadets like
summer camp you know what I mean I don't
know when that's gonna come back I don't
know when they're gonna be another like
one of those that [ __ ] is just so fun
some of the best times Wilson will see
but who knows but anyways guys this is
big Godfrey you can see him on in
Godfrey we trust
that's his podcast it's on what's a
network again Oh gasps Digital Network
and promo code Godfrey and also my
instagram is keys my Instagram and all
that information below you guys look
below all his information will be there
yes you can be great
but anyways just good talking to you man
and I'll see you soon all right that's
good guys B everybody thank you very
much
[Music]